tout au long de la journée des voix à
gauche comme à droite ont dénoncé les
propos tenus hier soir par marine le pen
candidate à la présidence du front
national marine le pen a comparé les
prières de rue de musulmans à une
occupation proportion provoqué un
véritable tollé
béatrice gelot rideout aille jusqu'à
présent elle n'avait jamais déraper
d'ailleurs certains disent que marine le
pen c'est son père sans les provocations
verbales ce qui la rend fréquentable aux
yeux de nombreux politiques
mais aujourd'hui elle est en campagne
pour succéder à son père à la mi janvier
et pour séduire les historiques du front
national qui juge son discours trop
lisse elle vient de le radicaliser à
lyon dans le fief de son adversaire
bruno gollnisch
ceux qui pratiquent les prières sur la
voie publique se comportent comme des
occupants
aussitôt c'est toute la classe politique
qui condamnent ses propos à gauche comme
à droite on est unanime
marine le pen a dérapé en matière de
lutte contre l'occupation
ce sont des arabes des musulmans des
africains des régiments entiers de
tirailleurs qui ont participé et qui ont
perdu leur vie l'on sacrifié cette
déclaration
est une injure et une injure à ceux qui
arabes africains musulmans ou non sont
morts pour la france c'est pas un
changement de prénom à la tête du front
national qui changera quoi que ce soit
ce qu'elle front national une impasse
si le front national avait quoi que ce
soit d'intéressant à dire face aux
problèmes des français ça se saurait
c'était déjà pas le cas avec son père ce
sera certainement jamais le cas avec
elle ce soir marine le pen se justifie
tout en essayant de banaliser ces
paroles ça démontre une chose cette
indignation organisé et c'est d'abord
ils ont peur de moi parce que je monte
dans les sondages c'est ça la vraie
raison est la deuxième le deuxième
constat qu'on peut en tirer c'est qu'on
ne peut pas donc compter sur l'ump le ps
les verts le parti communiste ou
n'importe quel autre parti pour régler
ce problème de la perte de notre
souveraineté territoriale dans toute une
série d' endroit qui se multiplient le
garde des sceaux michel mercier exclu
une action en justice contre marine le
pen